des locaux flambant neuf une surface de
400 mètres carrés attrape le nouveau
centre de santé municipal a ouvert ses
portes il y a près d'un mois la règle
d'or ici les consultations sont
conventionnées secteur 1 et le tiers
payant est appliqué quel que soit le
niveau de revenus le niveau de vie de
tous les habitants qu'ils puissent avoir
qu'il soit
nantis ou non qu'il puisse avoir des
soins qui soient d'aussi bonne qualité
que si vous alliez dans un cabinet en
libéral ou ou à l'hôpital le privé de
l'Ouest parisien etc médecin généraliste
gynécologue
orthophoniste ou encore allergologue 11
professionnels de santé accueillent les
patients tous sont en temps partiels et
travaillaient déjà à l'ancien centre de
santé Yves Lafarge un centre datant de
plus de 40 ans devenu très obsolètes et
aujourd'hui définitivement fermée on a
retrouvé d'abord un peu plus d'espace
puisque effectivement on est dans des
locaux neufs là-bas
c'était deux appartements là on a de la
lumière qui arrive partout
on a des locaux qui sont quand même plus
plus aérés etc maintenant les personnes
qui sont sur chaise roulante ils peuvent
rentrer aussi voilà on est au nord donc
c'est vrai que c'est pour nous quelque
chose d'important 2 millions et demi
d'euros c'est le coût global de cette
nouvelle structure létale la communauté
d'agglomération ou encore la région
participer aux financement et la ville
de Trappes est majoritaire a plus de
50%. les patients sont au rendez-vous
les délais d'attentes s'allongent déjà
des recrutements pourraient être
envisagées à court terme